hey what's going on everybody i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message for today
june 23rd 2021
do me a solid and uh subscribe to the
youtube channel
tap the notification bell share a video
it's no skin off your back
sure you're going to freak out your blue
and on cousin but
try it see what happens uh guys this
is a big week before i get into
the specifics of today's show uh i want
to tease
an interview that i will be doing on
friday you may have heard of this guy
he is the former president of the united
states
an orange man a man
who fought the media had some big wins
had some tough losses has an
undetermined future that's right
i am interviewing former president
donald
j trump on friday
we've been going back and forth with his
team i got to tell you they're actually
pretty great and they've made it clear
that really nothing
is off limits so we shall see
what happens obviously i've got a couple
ideas
and you know i'm gonna i'm gonna do the
best i can to try to cover some new
ground and not just do all the rehash
stuff but i'm obviously extremely
excited
about this we're doing this on friday
and i normally don't do this i don't
think i've ever done this actually in
the i don't know how many hundreds or
thousands of interviews
that i've ever done but we will take one
question in advance from the audience i
never go out
and ask the audience i see a lot of
interview viewers do this and i always
find it kind of cheap
like what do you want me to ask this
person it's like do your job right like
you know
that's just part of the job as an
interviewer no one more questions asked
but i will take one question
from our locals community so you can go
ahead right now
and submit a question for president
donald
j trump at rubinreport.locals.com
his guys as i said have made it clear
that nothing's off limits we can talk
about
anything i don't know that everything we
talk about can be put on youtube so
we'll
have to deal with that and again that is
why i started that tech company over
there
uh but we're going to try to do a little
bit of everything and and see what
happens so that is happening
on friday i'm obviously super psyched
and
i will discuss with my team what is the
best way
to approach such an interview in a time
of political chaos and ridiculous
censorship
guys we've got three stories for you
today first off you know i keep talking
about how
the democrats are really here at this
point to destroy
everything when you think about the
democrats you have to now know they're
not your parents democrats and they're
certainly not your grandparents
democrats they're
basically socialists collectivists and
marxists
they believe that the government should
pretty much do everything and if you
can't get everything done by your state
government
then yeah you hand it over to the
federal government which is the reverse
of how the united states is supposed to
operate we're supposed to be a
collection of states
that make some decisions and then you
know some of the
really important stuff say like borders
and things like that and defense are
handed over the feds
but the democrats now are talking about
a federal takeover of elections
uh which again as far as i'm concerned
it's completely against the constitution
of the united states and i think there
will be all sorts of legal battles but
they're trying to do it
and they know that they get almost no
pushback because you know mainstream
media corporate press
as michael malus says is basically their
their tag
team partner in this so you know one of
the things that
donald j trump knew about was that it's
not just republicans
fighting democrats it's republicans or
let's say conservatives whatever you
want to call it
fighting democrats liberals lefties and
the corporate press so they've got
a tag team duo over here fighting one
guy over here there's an asymmetry over
there
so we're gonna talk about that then uh
we're gonna go down the
the woke the woke road it never stops
it never stops the emmys which are the
yearly tv
awards for the best actors the best
writers you know these people who are
better than us
who we give all our money to and then
they tell us how horrible we are well
the emmys
is no longer going to be giving out
awards based on gender
because tolerance diversity something
like that
they're only going to be giving out
performer now it won't be about
actor or actress anymore because
obviously this is going to lead us to
being a much
better country and more tolerant people
uh and then finally
on the really interesting side of the
woke thing right now
the emmys i was just sort of throwing it
there because it's like nobody even
cares about the emmys anymore you know
the ratings
just keep tanking and tanking like the
oscars and nba all these things keep
tanking and tanking
the more they go woke and yet they keep
using that as fuel to go even more woke
like they're trying to drown themselves
or something
but a rare counter to that you may
remember a couple weeks ago this story
was blowing up online how
coca-cola was going with all of these
crazy woke policies and diversity
and inclusion and they were they were
going to have basically racial quotas
and gender and sexuality quotas
related to the people that they hire and
the companies they would work with and
all that
well you're not going to believe this
but some of that turns out to be against
the law
so they're actually reversing it so i
guess they're deciding that
you know they were going all in on
everybody's racist and then the lawyers
were like
guys no that's a problem because you
can't
hire people based on the color of their
skin that's sort of what the old racists
wanted to do it's a little more
i know you're calling everybody nazis
all the time but that's a little more
nazi-like so
anyway we're going to get into all of
that and again if you want to submit a
question for president trump
rubenreport.locals.com
and guys before i do anything else i
want to talk to you about
bonner private wine guys you know next
time you grill up a couple of steaks
pop open a bottle of extreme altitude
malbec wine i'm holding one in my hand
right now
it comes from these remote vineyards in
argentina located up at around 9000 feet
when these vintners aren't making wine
they're herding cattle so they know
meat they know barbecue and that's
exactly what these malbecs are for
as soon as you open the bottle you're
going to experience delicious notes of
blackberry leather smoke and a little
dark cherry
you're also going to get less sugar less
chemicals and less additives and 10
times more resveratrol which is a
powerful longevity booster if i'm not
mistaken barbara walters used to bathe
in resveratrol that's what was keeping
her young
and yes i do bust out the the malbec
whenever i'm making one of my rib eyes
that you guys
see over at locals the guys over at
freethinkerwine.com got a special
shipment of these wines in
and they've got one malbec from the
third highest vineyard in the world
almost 9 000 feet visit
freethinkerwine.com today and you'll get
50
off the wine and 50 off shipping this is
a small batch and it's going to go fast
so visit
freethinkerwine.com that's
freethinkerwine.com and now back to me
you know one of the nice things about
certain sponsors is when they've got a
great product
you get a lot of messages after them
people are sending me
pictures drinking wine eating steaks all
that good stuff and
i love seeing that because that means
we've got you know uh partners on this
show that are doing good for you guys
too and it's sort of win-win for
everybody beautiful thing okay
uh so let's talk about this uh election
situation
so there was a question asked of jen
pasaki now i know her name
is uh it's a silent p it's actually gen
saki from what i'm told
i've been saying jen vasaki this whole
time i kind of like it at this point and
i think i'm just going to keep doing it
so there we go that's that's how we're
going to do it around here she is the
white house press secretary
this woman is completely incapable of
saying
anything even remotely close to honest
and you know look you're a press
secretary it's your job
to just like spew [ __ ] that's pretty
much what your job is right there's like
some level of truth that's happening in
reality related to the administration
and the president and the decisions and
all that
and then there's people asking you
questions in the press and even though
they're
democrats so they're getting softball
questions for the most part she has to
act basically as the force field right
so her job is to just like stop truth
from getting
to you know stop the journalists who
want real information from getting the
truth so she's acting as the force field
of the truth and this woman just babbles
on and on and on and rarely says
anything of value and when she does
say something that sounds like sort of
an actual statement
it's usually the reverse of the truth
well right now one of the things that
the democrats are pushing
is this idea that we should have the
federal
government in charge of elections this
is against
the constitution it is against the way
the government was set up
states are supposed to decide what their
laws are related to elections that's the
way it's always been that's the way it
should be
you don't want the giant machine telling
us all what to do i i don't
you know if you don't get that at this
point like if you're walking around if
there's someone in the united states
walking around going yes
that giant federal government machine
it's doing so much good stuff if it
could only have more money and control
more parts of my life and it could
only manage our elections and everything
else like you got to see a doctor
like see a therapist at that point if
you're walking around thinking that
well anyway of course the democrats want
to get the power
out of the states and they want the
federal government to take
over all the elections do you think this
is possibly
because they want to ensure that they
win all the elections or is it really
because
they're so worried about what's
happening at a state level and by the
way i'm going to give you some specifics
about some of these laws that they keep
saying are racist and everything else
anyway jem pasaki was asked about this
and you're not going to believe it guys
she managed to blame the january 6th
insurrection
follow up on on voting rights here um
yesterday you said that there's more
work to be done
among that is including engaging state
legislatures
but the problems as democrats at least
see it is not
problems in blue states state
legislatures it's republican controlled
states where many of these decisions
are already being made so what leverage
do you actually have and
what realistically do you think you can
accomplish in some of these these red
states
well first i think uh the point we've
been making is that
it's part a federal approach that is
needed and i think it's important to
remember why we're at this point um
state legislatures as you referenced
across the country are passing a wave of
anti-voter laws based on the same
repeatedly disproven lies
that led to an assault on our nation's
capital they are putting these laws in
place because they did not like the
outcome and they've continued to
perpetuate
a lie about the outcome of the election
that's why we're here
uh what the president and what the vice
president will do is
engage with voting rights groups engage
with legislators who are supportive of
expanding access
to voting around the country yes there
are even in red states there are many
democratic legislators or legislators
who want to expand that access
empower them work with them support them
in these efforts
and continue to fight to get legislation
across the finish line on the federal
level
so this fight is not over no matter the
outcome today
it is going to continue okay a lot of
words there by miss
pasaki but not a lot of information she
did say two things that i thought were
interesting
she state said that state legislatures
are passing anti-voting laws and this is
the meme
that we're getting from corporate press
that somehow in republican states
florida texas
tennessee you know the scary states
that they're passing laws georgia to
stop
uh people from being able to vote and
that is somehow done in the name of
racism or something like that now notice
she never mentions any of the specifics
in the bills so i'm going to get to some
of the specifics
in some of these bills a lot of this is
around the new bill that was just passed
sb 202 in georgia i'll give you some of
the specifics and you can decide for
yourself
if it's about stopping people from
legitimately voting
or not um she also linked this by
linking it to january 6
she's saying they're perpetuating the
lie that the election
was rigged or something to that effect
these are the very same people
who for four years told us that donald
trump was a fraudulent
president that russia hacked our
election that ukraine did something and
actually that had far more to do with
hunter biden and joe biden than anything
related to the
trump family so these people they
lie and then they tell you that you're
the liar
this is a big problem there is a still
right now a tweet up from hillary
clinton
claiming that donald trump was an
illegitimate president right so we had
four years of you guys doing all this
nonsense
but now they see an opportunity because
they feel they have enough power in the
senate with the tiebreaker through
kamala
they feel that they can actually just
completely
nationalize and federalize the election
and trust me
trust me they're not doing it because
they want
more people to vote fairly they're doing
it
because they want to ensure that they
will always win that they will make sure
that as many illegals vote
as many people who don't have ids can do
all sorts of fraudulent stuff and
everything else why else would you not
want
someone to have an id to vote but
let's listen to what the folks at the
daily wire said about this and then i
will tell you some of the things
in the bill itself because i give you
information around here as opposed to
these dingbats
like pasaki uh the legislation seeks and
this is the georgia legislation seeks to
tighten up elections and reduce
fraud by enforcing conformity across the
state amping up voter id
restricting drop boxes and expanding
in-person voting among
additional election related overhauls so
let me pause and let's just
discuss those again okay so what are
they trying to do in georgia are they
trying to stop
black people or gay people or invalids
from voting what are they actually
trying to do well here's what the
law is trying to do they are trying to
reduce fraud by conforming
across the state so meaning the state
will have policies across the state so
cities can't do all sorts of different
things that will hopefully
reduce fraud by doing it purely at a
state level so that if you're in one
city
in georgia they don't have punch cards
and the other one has this we're going
to try to do it all across the state
okay that sounds
that sounds right that doesn't seem
racist or mean or
you know demeaning to anyone amping up
voter id
well it seems to me call me an
old-fashioned racist
but it seems to me that if you're going
to go vote you should have to
show an id oh i'm dave and i'm a person
that lives in this district and i'm
trying to vote for this candidate
as opposed to literally anyone walking
in
and saying yes oh i live at 10402 walter
avenue
let me vote but that's what they're
doing i live in this banana republic
of los angeles in the in the psychotic
state of california
and when i voted in the presidential
election i told you
i've told you guys this before i tried
to show my guy the id the guy that was
sitting there
and these people are no wizards you know
that are running the election things
and he literally was like no no no like
he didn't even want to see it
they just asked me for my name and
address i had actually moved i'm not
even sure i had given them the right
address and then you go ahead and do it
i know my neighbor's address and my
neighbor's name i could have literally
showed up the next day and voted so just
to be clear
these are not things having an id a
government issued id which you need
a government issue id to buy beer or to
get on a plane
or to rent a bicycle they often want to
see your id actually last time i went
mini golfing
to rent the golf club they wanted to see
an id i think they held
the id actually because they want to
make sure you don't steal the golf club
so basically
mini golf is now more secure than our
elections uh so amping up voter id
restricting drop boxes okay so they want
to have a more controlled amount of drop
boxes this is where people early vote
you know you get the thing mailed to you
at home
and then you can just put it in one of
these drop boxes
i would want to know a little bit more
about that restricting dropbox is what
that mean
but it sounds like they were very
unsecure in the last election and by
restricting the amount of them
perhaps you're able to actually track
who's voting and the rest of it
uh and expanding in-person voting
expanding not taking away we're going to
expand imperson voting because we want
to attach a human being to the vote
right so that seems good
among additional election related
overhauls so again
they keep saying this and and just note
this
when you watch them talk about election
bills on cnn
and on msnbc and when you read about it
you know not that you wise people are
reading about in the washington post or
in the new york times or anything else
but they never tell you what the
criticisms are they just tell you it's
racist they never tell you
well they they don't let won't let
people drink water on the lines if
someone wants to bring you water well
they don't want
people canvassing saying i'm for
ex-candidate here's some water will you
vote for ex-candidate like we all know
that
and by the way i'm not opposed to people
having water when they're voting and
there's a long line but bring water like
we've just
outsourced all personal responsibility
all the time all right let's go back
the bill's provisions add id
requirements
for absentee by mail ballots okay so
that means if you're gonna
do a mail-in ballot you gotta show some
form of id as opposed to being a random
person
or a russian operative who might be
mailing in some ballots
when georgians return their ballots they
will be required to use a form of id to
verify who they are
racist sb 202 also expands
in-person voting access with counties
allowed to add more hours
including on the weekends as they saw
fit okay so i think you get it and by
the way this is
very very similar to i'm talking about
georgia right here but these
types of laws that pasaki's worried
about that in these red states
they're you know they did an
insurrection and now they don't want
anybody to
vote fairly and they want to stop black
people from voting and blah blah
it's all pure [ __ ] like that's
it it's just perfect pure [ __ ]
that's exactly what it is if you can
show me
and i will look in the comments today if
you can show me
something in one of these bills that is
racist or homophobic or bigoted or
designed to stop people from voting
more in-person access showing ids
expanding to the weekend these are
things that will allow more people to
vote and allow us to
feel more confident in the voting system
let's put it this way
you person watching this right now hello
person watching this on youtube right
now
okay with your porn tab open i know what
you're doing over there
let's think about it this way do you
that was really disturbing to think that
people could have a porn tab open while
they're watching me very upsetting
um not you i know you're good decent
americans um
do you feel that right now
the system is working perfectly do you
feel totally confident about our state
or federal elections or anything else
i'm going to guess the answer is no and
and oddly that seems to be something
we're all agreeing on the democrats
seem to think it's very flawed right
that's why they want to pass federal
mandates and the republicans obviously
think it's very
uh flawed because they're not thrilled
with the results of the last election
and
whatever else oh i probably just got
booted from from youtube
uh it was nice knowing all of you
reubenreport.locals.com anyway the point
is across the board we all sort of think
something's wrong with the election
process
so the basic things that we should be
able to agree on
is that maybe more days weekends
ids so who are the ones trying to stop
that and who are the ones trying to push
that through
i think i have made my point thank you
very much
all right let's talk about the emmys so
look hollywood is just awful i say that
as someone that lives like two minutes
from hollywood
hollywood itself i mean the physical
location of hollywood
is an absolute disaster if you want to
see what a dystopian future looks like
drive to hollywood sometime and just
drive down hollywood boulevard and what
used to be so great by the chinese
theater
and uh you know they were all well
there's many theaters there and just
like what what was so cool about
hollywood you know the stars
the walk of fame and like all these cool
bars and you and comedy clubs
and places to listen to like you know
groundbreaking musicians and awesome
clubs and all this stuff it used to be
so
awesome there really was something cool
about hollywood at some point
and really for decades probably now
hollywood has just become this woke
disaster and then because it's
here in los angeles with these with our
ridiculous progressive mayor eric
garcetti who have
did are they sending him to india yet or
not do we know he's going
all right so this is fantastic news can
we confirm that's absolutely official
that is legit
yeah it's official so eric garcetti is
going to be our ambassador to india so
we're getting rid of them
which is wonderful i mean that's really
great i should i should have we should
have had shots on the show today i
should have done a shot right now
um where we're getting rid of him but
anyway all the you know all the policies
that these people bring in it expands
the homelessness and the drug use and
the tent cities and all that so
hollywood's really disgusting right now
uh actually my uh my girl who uh who
does my hair she lives in hollywood
and she great little girl like totally
cool normal
you know she lives in a little walk up
there with her dog like a homeless
person literally was chasing her down
the street two weeks ago like it's just
it's just awful there anyway that's the
physical part of hollywood but the
the underneath part of hollywood is the
way they
run the business and we all know it's
just become this woke disastrous thing
and it's ironic
because you know they're really here to
make money and you'd think that an
industry like hollywood or any industry
that's here to make money wouldn't want
to alienate basically half the country
but that seems to be the route that
they're going and wokism destroys
everything
so they emmys now which no one watches
anymore right the ratings go down
every year can we get a number on that
of what the ratings have dropped with
the
with the emmys over the last couple
years uh they are no longer going to
have
actor and actress awards we are going to
have
a performer it's going to be performer
good god help me
we got some quotes here from fox news
the emmy awards are giving nominees the
option to be more
gender inclusive with their statues the
television academy's board of governors
announced monday that it has approved
rule changes that will allow nominees an
option to request that their nomination
certificate and possibly emmy statuette
use the term performer rather than actor
or actress
the move answers recent calls from
gender non-conforming
stars to make the award system less
dependent on pronouns and gendered
casting
no performer category titled actor or
actress
has ever had a gender requirement for
submissions
the television academy wrote on tuesday
via deadline
now nominees and or winners in any
performer
category titled actor or actress may
request that their nomination
certificate
an emmy statuette carry the term
performer
in the place of actor or actress
look guys i don't think this story is
like the biggest thing like this is one
where you can just sort of put it aside
at the end of the day you know sometimes
we do some important stuff like voting
stuff
is important the critical race theory
stuff is important all that kind of
stuff
this is this type of story though that i
wanted to do
because it just is more evidence that
they just destroy everything thank you
for that michael september 2020 so last
year's emmys
were the lowest uh all-time
6.1 million viewers i'm actually shocked
that it was that high but
you can see what they're doing they're
destroying their own industry and that
was making me think about something
i'm sure some of you guys either read
the book i believe the author was bill
carter if i'm not mistaken
uh the author of the book late shift the
late shift it was also a made for
tv movie on hbo about 20 25 years ago
and what it was about was uh the
the when johnny carson left the tonight
show and obviously he had been at the
helm of the tonight show for probably 30
years something like that
that david letterman who was at nbc at
the time really wanted the tonight show
and jay leno was also subbing in for
johnny carson all the time and he really
wanted the tonight show
and nbc was jockeying like what do we do
here they wanted to give it
to leno uh but letterman really wasn't
gonna stay
i don't have to get into all the
specifics of all that obviously you guys
know what happened
leno got the tonight show and it
actually did well in the ratings for 20
years
and in a weird way i never loved jay
leno but i sort of miss him now because
these people are all such parties and
hacks
but letterman left and then did i guess
what he called the late show on cbs
the reason i mention all this is there's
a really great moment
in the movie where letterman is like
freaking out because his whole life
he wanted the tonight show he wanted the
tonight show that was hosted by jack
parr and johnny carson and all the great
people
before that and his manager one of his
like close confidants
he's like he's like dave you got to get
over it
you think you're getting the johnny
carson tonight show
but it's damaged goods it's damaged
goods
and that's sort of what all of these
awards will now be
we will do everything based on equity
and inclusion and we will say that we
have to have
you know more black trans winners of
genderless categories of acting and
lighting and all of these things
but the entire thing that they'll all be
going for
will be damaged goods it will not be
like getting an
emmy when maybe it mattered i get it an
emmy in and of itself is not the most
important thing in the world
but i used to care about that sort of
thing like it was fun to watch those
things and fun to watch actors you care
about
and good pieces of art like we need art
right we need music we need movies
and things to capture our imagination
and the rest of it but in essence
the emmys are now damaged goods
hollywood is damaged good so all of
these people that will be like yes this
is so great
will have diversity and equity and
inclusion and there won't be actors and
actresses we'll all just be performers
and you know we'll and then 70 of the
people who win will be
black trans latin x people with a limp
and a lazy eye and everything else
and what they will be winning is not
really an emmy at that point
it will be damaged goods so
that's what i think about that again
this isn't the most important story but
it's like all right
let them the beauty of this is let them
destroy their things
let them destroy their things and how
about the rest of us keep building
things
that's that's my plan uh the third story
is an interesting reversal
on all of this because coca-cola uh
they were going fully woke now again i
don't think any of these capitalist
companies believe in woke i think they
they're doing it to make more money it's
the ultimate capitalist move you got to
kind of respect the hustle there
but they're suddenly finding out that
when you go fully woke you're probably
breaking the law because you're racist
we've got some quotes here from reuters
a group of shareholders of coca-cola
company threatened legal action
against the company's board on friday
unless it
ends what they allege are illegal
policies that the company adopted in
january
to promote diversity among outside
lawyers the advocacy
group wrote to koch's board claiming the
diversity policy violates the civil
rights act
and the american the americans with
disabilities act so what
is it exactly that they were going to do
the post-millennial lays it out for us
on june 11th the american civil rights
project
sent a warning letter to coca-cola
alleging that the beverage corporation's
new diversity polity would require
contracted law firms to violate
anti-discrimination law
the letter asks the recently beleaguered
company to either publicly retract the
discriminatory outside counsel policies
it announced in january or otherwise
provide access to the corporate records
related to the decision
of coca-cola's officers and directors to
adopt and retain those illegal policies
and this is the key part the current
diversity policy in place at coca-cola
requires that the company commit that at
least 30
percent of the build associate and
partner time will be from
diverse attorneys and of such amounts
that at least
half will be from black attorneys
so now they could be in a lot of trouble
it's not just that drinking coke will
kill you because you're having like
i don't know how many teaspoons of sugar
or in a can of coke we do this every few
months it's a lot of sugar you're just
putting a lot of sugar
try some club soda if you need something
bubbly
putting that aside they were basically
saying yes
we are going to hire in this case
outside lawyers uh by the basis of the
color of their skin and at least 50
of them had to be black at the 30 i
guess you could maybe have some
latinos or something like that but in
essence we will discriminate
against white people we will
discriminate
against asian people and that is
illegal okay so now the board is in a
lot of trouble
so the lawyers are going to have to
figure this thing out and and this is
why you should be hopeful about woke it
is so
obviously racist it is so obviously
counter to equality
and account and um and the reverse of
all the principles that that most of us
have loved but maybe we forgot that we
had to keep fighting for them
but it's so obviously against all of
this stuff that eventually
not only will it overstep which it's
doing right now but then the legal
system i mean
maybe all we got left is the legal
system right like so the legislative
system
they're not going to fix anything the
democrats are in control of stuff right
now so they're not going to fix anything
at a state level we know that you know a
guy like desantis banning critical race
theory that that's working a little bit
but then basically let's get the
democrats and the socialists and the
marxists and the bernies and the hamas
caucus and all of them
let's get them to defend discrimination
because that's what they're
trying to do they're trying to make us
discriminate
i don't want to discriminate
discriminate against white people i
don't want to discriminate against asian
people
or black people or gay people which
reminds me
jobs we're hiring and i don't give a
flying [ __ ] what color you are
or what your gender is or what sexuality
you are
do you know how to do the job do you
work hard
are you a decent person you might get a
job with us and we're hiring in miami
right now so
jobs.locals.com and don't drink coke
anyway don't drink coke we're having a
big party here for my 45th on saturday
we got some coke because you just feel
like you should have a coke at a party
you should have
coca-cola that is i'm a little old for
the rest of that you know
but the point is uh you know some people
expect it but i was like ah
we really have to have this in the house
but we got a couple cans of coke by the
way there are 39
grams of sugar in a 12-ounce coca-cola
really google what that means it's an
awful lot you just don't need that much
younger people
in closing part two of my interview with
michael knowles
from the daily wire whose new book
speechless came out yesterday and from
what i understand it's doing quite well
uh that is up on youtube right now and
the full episode is up five days early
and ad free
at reubenreport.locals.com i will uh be
keeping an eye out for those questions
for trump so again if you want to i will
do it i've never done it before but if
you want to get a question in for trump
you can submit it at
reubenreport.locals.com all right we got
a busy day over here
so enjoy your day everybody and just
keep fighting
keep fighting i'm going to keep fighting
you keep fighting
let's see what happens all right see ya